aunque la buenas tardes este es otro
reconocimiento más de un grupo de
militares y de manera particular de un
alto mando sobre hechos que los
militares y la institución previamente
ha reconocido como cierto y que ha
llevado a la cárcel a muchos de estos
señores he leído el documento del
general es un documento reflexivo es un
documento pragmático un documento que se
acusa de haber faltado al deber de celo
es decir él no participó activamente en
ninguno de estos homicidios
faltó que tuviera el debido celo y que
por omisión él cargará con esa culpa
como comandante militar creo que es un
paso importante para la institución
militar colombiana en el reconocimiento
de hechos que evidentemente sucedieron
pero que se han tornado en un
instrumento político mire y entretanto
las víctimas de falsos positivos no
querían que este caso lo tratara la
gente porque decían que no pertenecía el
conflicto armado sino que era un crimen
de estado usted qué opina
pues que ellos dicen eso pero las
víctimas de los crímenes de lesa
humanidad de los grupos armados ilegales
piensan lo contrario y entonces aquí si
hay un viejo dicho que dice todos en la
cama o todos en el suelo y ese usted que
algunos partidos políticos y algunos
voceros caracterizados han pedido
persistentemente que se cree una sala
especial para los militares porque el
rasero que se está aplicando ha igualado
la institucionalidad con el crimen
transnacional organizada
y finalmente frente a este avance en la
justicia especial para la paz
tenemos que seguir preguntando quién dio
la orden de qué están haciendo ustedes
para que esto no vuelva a pasar
esa autorización para colocar afiches y
colocar pósters y colocar murales con
quien dio la orden es una un
linchamiento mediático que ha sido
autorizado por las altas cortes
colombianas que estamos haciendo
nosotros desde a core todos los
oficiales en retiro y desde hace muchos
años desde que prestaron los diálogos en
la habana hemos manifestado nuestra
inconformidad con un acuerdo que llevó a
que la gente fuera legal pero no
legítima porque insistimos más de la
mitad de los colombianos en un
plebiscito amplio abierto y sin
presiones consideró que no era necesario
no era oportuno y no era conveniente
para firmar esos acuerdos